Okay.
Hi everyone.
Thank you all for coming.
Good afternoon and welcome to toxic Google Cambridge.
Uh,
I'm honored today to introduce Samantha Laken.
Samantha is a coming Cummings Foundation fellow and a phd student at the stress
or center for Holocaust and genocide studies,
genocide studies at Clark University and as Alumna of the Fletcher school at
Tufts University and at Brandeis University.
She has interviewed and researched Holocaust survivors as a Fulbright Fulbright
scholar to Switzerland and is a grantee with the national endowment for the
humanities.
She continues to work with the World Health Organization on worldwide gender
issues.
Samantha has presented at a number of international conferences including the
University of London at the International Institute for Holocaust research at
Yad Vashem,
the museum of tolerance in New York and the international society of political
psychology.
She's a consultant for the Kigali genocide memorial and the Egis trust in Rwanda
and on the advisory board of the genocide survivors support network.
Samantha's research explores the stories of survivors of the 1,994 to two t
genocide in Rwanda and how their experiences affect their current communities.
She focuses on memorials rebuilding and the transitional justice of the Rwandan
community.
Please help me welcome Samantha Lichens.
Hi,
good afternoon everyone.
Uh,
thank you so much for joining me here.
My name is Samantha Laken and asking the tough said.
Um,
I am a current phd student at the strats are center for Holocaust and genocide
studies at Clark University.
And what I want to do today is give you a little bit of information and insight
about my journey.
Um,
working with survivors of genocide and conflict and also looking at issues of
transitional justice and how societies recover from a conflict and genocide to
peace.
And I'm going to do that in um,
a very special way.
What I feel is very special.
Um,
I'm going to do that by taking you through a number of themes and stories that
kind of highlight,
uh,
the post conflict and post genocide landscape in Rwanda today.
Um,
to give you a sense of those types of places and spaces that I've been able to
enter a while doing this work for the past six years.
Um,
and to help you rethink and reframe your own conceptions of post genocide and
postconflict justice,
whatever that means to you.
And I'm hoping that by the end of this talk you'll have seen some new things,
uh,
seen some new sites through the photos,
most,
most of which I've taken.
And also,
um,
learn to think a little bit differently about the successes and challenges that
we often experience through the media,
um,
or through other stories that we've heard sitting here in Cambridge and how they
affect people,
um,
in Rwanda and in around the world at large.
Um,
so the talk today is called from genocide to dignity and justice.
And basically the main questions I want to address are these.
I want you to think about what themes make up the landscape of post genocide
Rwanda.
And don't worry if you don't know too much about Rwanda right now cause I'll be
giving you a bit of information in a minute.
And the second thing I want to do is challenge us to rethink our framing,
um,
and assumptions about conflict and recovery and to use the stories that I'm
going to tell you.
And the experiences that I'm going to share with you,
um,
to understand these realistic goals,
developments,
challenges,
and areas for future and involvement.
And a while,
you know,
I was speaking with Madoff beforehand.
This subject sounds like something about genocide and death.
Um,
my goal is actually to get us thinking differently and reframing our ideas and
conceptions about what recovery means to a place where we're not sitting
depressed thinking about how Rwanda was in 1994 but we are thinking about ways
that transitional justice and others justice initiatives can really help
societies recover and thinking about that in a realistic and focused way.
So when we think of post genocide Rwanda,
what comes to mind is it's something like this.
Okay.
Or is it something like this?
The first photo is from one of the national memorial sites to genocide in Rwanda
and show us some of the scars and the bullet holes.
For example,
on the skulls of genocide victims.
This and image speaks about,
um,
three women who graduated from Aga Hosel Shalom youth village,
uh,
running and having fun in their village on the day of their graduation.
In there,
a cap and gown.
So very contrasting images to get us started.
So I want to give you a snapshot of Rwanda.
Um,
so basically Rwanda is a country in um,
eastern Central Africa.
Um,
and I'll show you a map in a minute where there are about 12 million people
living the languages are Kenya,
Rwanda,
English,
French,
and some Swahili spoken.
Most of the country is Catholic or Protestant,
um,
with a small minority of Muslims and non affiliated religious.
It borders Burundi,
the Democratic Republic of the Congo,
DRC,
Tanzania and Uganda.
But what's amazing is it's approximately the size of the state of Maryland.
So when you look at the map,
if you haven't seen where Rwanda is,
you'll be pretty amazed that little red.in that kind of the central east of
Africa is the country of Rwanda.
Uh,
looking at the entire continent of Africa,
that small mat,
that small dot,
the red,
uh,
is the country of.
So it's very small.
Territorially
and I'm,
I want to give you a little bit of history about the genocide in Rwanda.
I don't want to focus too much today on the history.
That's not what I'm here to do.
What I'm here to do is really,
um,
help you bring you into some spaces about the reconstruction and a
reconciliation processes in Rwanda.
So I'm going to go through this a little bit quickly.
If you have questions in the end,
please let me know.
But I just want to give you a background so you can kind of have an
understanding of what happened.
So,
um,
in 1994,
there was a genocide that took place in Rwanda.
Um,
the population at the time was about 84% who to about 15% Tutsi and about 1% of
indigenous trois people.
And the story goes that the history goes that,
um,
the Belgian colonial powers helped,
uh,
construct these identities,
who to the majority Tutsi,
the minority,
um,
and also had put Tutsi in power as kind of indirect rulers during Belgian
colonization.
And this created a lot of conflict between the Hutu and Tutsi communities.
Um,
and I'm saying communities because Hutu and Tutsi are not exactly ethnic
identities.
Uh,
in Rwanda,
everybody speaks the same language.
Kenya,
Rwanda,
I had come from similar backgrounds.
So these divisions were not particularly salient or meaningful until,
uh,
the Belgian colonizers came to power.
So again,
they favored the Tutsi who basically they gave a lot of positions to in,
in government and in education.
And,
um,
after that,
the Hutu extremist government came to power in the first and second republic
and,
um,
started to persecute the Tutsi population between 1959 and 1994 in 1994 on the
6th of April,
that,
that who to hardliner,
President Habyarimana,
um,
his plane was shot down on the 6th of April.
And on the seventh,
the Rwandan Armed Forces and the Interahamwe militia,
uh,
started the systematic killing of Tutsi and moderate Hutus.
Um,
and as we know,
many of us who were alive during this period or who were watching the news,
the international community really abandoned Rwanda.
Um,
we've even seen recent articles come out in foreign policy that,
um,
heads of state in the United States knew what was going on.
And we're concerned about calling it a genocide because of what intervention
would mean.
And so these debates are ongoing,
but in Rwanda,
people generally feel that United Nations and international community let them
down.
So the killings began and there were about 100 days of genocidal killings all
throughout the country with very popular involvement.
So,
um,
killings on the ground,
we call it low tech killing with machetes and clubs at other,
um,
other kind of household and farming,
uh,
weapons.
And I'm on the 4th of July.
In 1994,
the Rwandan Patriotic Front and the Rwandan Patriotic Army who been an exile and
Uganda,
uh,
came in,
took control of the capital city of Kigali,
uh,
liberated the country and started to form a transitional government.
So that's kind of the history we've got of what happened during the genocide.
Um,
so the current RPF,
Rwandan Patriotic Front love led government and the state in general has really
attempted to rebuild social order and social fabric in Rwanda since 1994.
And the goal of the state with regard to survivors,
which is specifically what I,
uh,
what I research,
um,
is threefold as identified by the state to provide security to combat genocide
ideology and denial and to reunite the country under the bonding in Rwanda that
we are all Rwandans.
We are all one Rwandan people and these ideals are very prevalent and have been
there since the end of the genocide in 1994 and are heavily present in the
reconstruction that we see today.
So just some statistics about survivors before we get into the meat,
the kind of good stuff,
uh,
where we're going to enter into these spaces.
And I'm going to tell you a little bit about these themes that I've identified
in the stories that go with them,
the experiences that I've had being in Rwanda and being with,
with different people.
Um,
but we have about 1 million genocide victims,
uh,
to see on moderate who to massacred in 1994 about 300,000 survivors with 58%
women.
I'm 64,000 or 65,000 orphans,
widows,
rape victims,
children born of rape,
which is a major issue right now in Rwanda and also handicapped.
So these are kind of some of the um,
scars that have been left after the genocide.
So these are the spaces of healing that I wanted to speak about and I've
identified basically five categories,
broad categories that I've really experienced that are taking place in Rwanda
today.
And as I said,
they have their challenges and their successes.
Um,
and what I really want to do is to introduce you to those challenges and
successes so that we can gain a really comprehensive understanding of how to
even start thinking about post conflict development.
You won't be experts by the end of the day,
but I'm hoping to give you something to take away that will allow you to think
about how you envisioned post conflict societies and what you might think after
this lecture.
So the spaces of healing,
development,
recovery,
truth and grief and Rwanda I've identified as memory,
justice,
youth and education,
psychological health and trauma,
healing and technology and research.
I'm also not going to try to give you kind of the standard examples today.
The ones that you've read in the news are the ones that you've seen a million
times.
What I'm going to try to do is take you through my experiences over the past
four years and help again enter into these spaces that are little known and that
you might not otherwise be able to see your access to help us broaden our
understanding.
So I want to take a deep breath and look at this really beautiful photo of a
sunset and a PA,
Eastern Province,
Rwanda,
uh,
where my God brother is from and survived from.
And I want you to just take a minute before we enter into these themes and I'm
think to yourself,
what does postconflict mean or look like?
Like we saw those two photos.
Does it look more like the skulls?
Does it look more like the graduates,
the women who have graduated high school?
What does it look like to you right now before we enter into this moment?
Okay,
I think we're ready.
The first thing I want to address his memory and I want to introduce you to
Omar.
Um,
this is Omar who is standing in the Yamato Memorial church where nearly 335,000
Rwandans were massacred in early April,
1994.
And Omar at 10 years old was only one of very few survivors,
um,
as he was a child,
he was able to hide under other people who had already been killed and,
um,
even,
uh,
was beaten on his legs and had to remain silent to a show that he was,
you know,
basically to prove that he was dead before they enter,
how my left and had escaped out of the church and into the community of Amata.
But,
um,
what was amazing is I have known Omar professionally through the Ngo world and
never really knew about his survival story.
But a one day we were eating lunch and Kigali and he said to me,
Samantha,
I know a lot about your work documenting testimonies and I'd like you to come
with me to knee Amata and to actually walk through the site with me and document
my story.
And I thought to myself,
oh great,
this is wonderful.
It will be good for my research.
It'll help my friend Omar go through his story.
Um,
but I didn't really realize how incredibly difficult and emotional it would be.
not only returning to the site but also returning to the site with a survivor of
the site who was also my friend.
And so these kinds of issues of memory were at play,
not only the surface issue where I can go in as a researcher and document
people's memories of the place.
The second element is not only am I documenting the memories,
but it was in the physical space itself,
which is a very intense.
And the third element was,
this is my friend,
this is someone I know and care about and work with.
So those three things were at play in my mind as we began driving out of Kigali
toward a bogus Sarah where the Amato memorial churches and in this photo Omar's
and the church,
the gray banner as a memorial banner.
And he's looking down at the benches which contained victim's clothing.
So those are clothing that were either left in the church,
are brought to the church,
uh,
from victims who had died during the genocide.
And you can see he's kind of thinking and he's actually standing in the place
where he survived.
He survived,
uh,
on the bench that he is right in front of.
And,
um,
what was pretty amazing about documenting Omar story is,
the kind of liberation had had for both me and for him.
Um,
for me,
I was trying to be professional and uh,
not to cry when my friend was telling me about his experiences,
which included listening to the children and women who are kind of at the
backside of the church by the altar,
who were crying.
And screaming for God.
He was hearing all of this and was recounting this to us.
And,
um,
I felt like I was causing him pain.
I felt like I was kind of poking him with something sharp and hurting him and I
didn't want to cause them any more pain,
but he had asked me to do this and he wanted to document the story and continue
to take us throughout the church and tell us about these experiences.
And there I was trying to be completely professional for my friend,
but inside feeling like I was really causing him pain and that was really hard
to deal with.
Um,
and so we ended up recording this.
I'm in a video form and a Omar now has it to share with his future family,
future children,
et cetera.
And uh,
it ended up being a really powerful experience,
but it took me really out of my element where I usually interview,
um,
individuals who I haven't met before and who I don't know and don't have a prior
relationship with trying to understand their relationship to memory and justice
issues in Rwanda.
Um,
so this was very different.
And what it showed though was how important the memory was to him.
That he wanted to do this as a way to honor his own memory,
but also to keep it for the future.
And so,
um,
one of the themes that,
I wanted to go through with memory is that,
um,
this mia motto memorial site is one of the six national memorial sites in
Rwanda.
Um,
and there are also many local memorial sites.
they're often like this with survivors clothing,
skulls of survivors,
uh,
caskets and other things left behind.
Um,
but to bring in some of these good things and the challenges,
you know,
um,
I wanted to talk about the purpose of having these memorial sites and having a
annual commemorations around them.
So commemoration period begins in Rwanda on April 7th,
um,
every year and lasts for about a hundred days.
And there are many local and national commemorative events.
And,
um,
during the commemoration we have testimonies,
poetry,
read a official speakers from government and from other communities,
uh,
often a comparative Lens.
And most of the population in Rwanda take part in these commemorations.
And so to get us thinking it's really about what is the purpose of the
commemoration.
At one point it brings survivors together and it provides validation of the
harms they've suffered.
It can educate people.
Um,
but sometimes there's also this view traumatization.
sometimes there are state goals or other goals that are at odds with survivors
goals.
And one survivor who I spoke with last week when I was preparing this told me
that people can be in the same physical commemoration space and be commemorating
and remembering different things,
which I think is something really interesting to think about how people can be
experiencing the same event yet be remembering it and,
and having different reactions.
So that's one of the challenges is how to make commemoration inclusive and bring
everyone in.
So this is for example,
something that happens at the commemoration.
This is a photo I took of some of the candles that are lit as people sit in
these kind of white plastic chairs.
And you could have anywhere between 500,000 people at one commemoration.
Sometimes there could be 30,
it depends on the type,
but I just wanted to give you small perspective.
The next thing I wanted to talk about is justice.
Justice is a huge,
huge subject and part of the benefit of justice is that it is a large subject.
So we don't have to be limited in the ways in which we think about justice.
Um,
and I know I'm not going to do justice to the subject of justice today,
but I do want to give you a little bit of history and take you into these
spaces.
So again,
this isn't Yamato Memorial Church.
You could see those benches and you can see the reeds that have been laid on the
ground there.
Um,
so this is kind of a bigger picture of the church.
so memorial sites are a form of symbolic justice,
which is one way to bring justice,
especially to survivors.
So in transitional justice,
we often think about courts.
We think about international criminal tribunals.
We think about local courts.
We think about the court system.
When we think about justice automatically when we say justice,
our mind goes to the lawyers.
And to the judges,
to the court systems,
which is good.
And there are many,
many positive benefits from court systems including holding perpetrators
accountable.
Um,
one of the things though that is that I focus on is what happens when the courts
close and when there is no longer a tyrannical justice.
And that's where the symbolic efforts such as apology and memorialization and
commemoration come into play,
which really focused less on perpetrators and more on survivors.
I just want to go through a story of a woman,
Bernadette who I met,
um,
interviewing,
uh,
during my fifth research trip in Rwanda.
And um,
we were sitting on the grass at the back of the knee motto Memorial Church.
Um,
it had been an hour long bus ride and we really,
um,
had come,
my interpreter and I adjust to interview Bernadette.
Now Bernadette was a caretaker,
uh,
at the memorial and most people didn't pay attention to her.
Uh,
they didn't know about her story,
but when I met her and started speaking a bit,
if you can in Rwanda with her,
I realized she had a lot more to discuss then,
uh,
might have led on a,
with her basically being a janitor,
a cleaning,
having a cleaning role.
And we basically,
I remember this day sitting barefoot on the grass there.
Uh,
the three women,
me,
my,
uh,
interpreter and Bernadette,
I'm asking questions about memory and justice and,
um,
she told me basically that she had been hiding,
and in place that was unfit for any human being.
She was hiding in a hole in the ground underneath some large banana leafs.
And the Rwandan Patriotic Front eventually found her,
um,
and she remembers them kind of picking her out of there and bringing her to a
safe spot and picking the bugs and the close up bugs out of her clothes and
hair.
And she defines this as her sense of justice,
which is the human decency that she was treated with in that moment of despair.
What she thought that the world had forgotten about her.
And so it's kind of from that perspective that I take,
uh,
an understanding of justice that justice could have multiple meanings for people
in the aftermath of genocide and conflict.
Um,
in addition to those legal forms of justice,
we also have many other forms of justice that we may not even know about or
might not even know to ask.
And one of the things I do in my research is trying to get at those other forms
and other definitions of justice that may provide more meaning for policy and
reconciliation programs.
Then kind of the traditional forms of justice.
So just something for us to think about.
Again,
these are children at the Naea Mata Memorial Church,
uh,
who are going on an official commemoration,
um,
bringing their wreath,
which is a really a common thing in Rwanda.
Um,
the next thing that I want to talk about his youth and education,
so this is gut cure.
Did a Nigga Kire and a I met [inaudible] through a friend,
a got curious is the author of a dreaming child,
which is this phenomenal book about a young people's experiences during the
genocide in Rwanda.
And I bring up,
um,
got curee because he is quite representative of the roles that young people had
to take.
Um,
in the aftermath of the genocide.
Now not every young person is interested in the history of genocide and that's,
that's normal.
But there are many people in Rwanda,
especially young people who are truly interested in trying to make sense and
have some the psychological process of meaning making of the experiences they
had,
whether they were two years old,
four years old,
10 years old.
They're still trying to make sense of what happened to their families and also
educate others.
And they really take this as a personal goal and got curious.
Book is an example of that.
Um,
the Curie was actually invited to Bogota Columbia to attend the international
book fair there.
And I had been working with him on getting grants and thanks to a number of
sponsors,
he was able to fly for the first time out of Rwanda to,
we'll go to,
and a,
I remember being on,
on Facebook messenger and I said,
how did it go?
How was the lecture?
And he said,
um,
there were 400 people there.
And I thought to myself,
400 people from Columbia and other places,
um,
asked,
came to hear you speak about your book,
that's pretty incredible and that impact is pretty amazing.
And I'm just to provide a statistic.
60% of Rwandans living in Rwanda are under the age of 25,
like a puree.
And so we have this,
um,
heavy burden but also opportunity put on the youth in Rwanda.
Um,
and there are other incredible things that they're doing that can tell you about
as well.
Um,
I also want to introduce you to Henry.
Henry is one of those graduates of Algos are Shalom youth village in Rwanda.
You can see his green cap and gown.
And I met Henry on my first visit,
first weekend in Rwanda where I was invited to the youth village to um,
attend their science fair.
And uh,
Henry was actually put in charge of the welcoming committee and he welcomed me
as a guest.
He didn't know me,
I didn't know him.
You know those relationships you think,
okay,
they're passing,
I'll meet him,
I'll go back.
I'll start my work,
that'd be fine.
It turned out that I gave Henry My,
uh,
email address and he started to write to me as he began to apply to colleges and
ask me advice.
And uh,
I was very apt to work with him.
He was a,
he's an incredible young men and,
uh,
basically,
um,
three years later,
Henry is now a second year student at Mcgill University.
Not only did he gain admission,
but he gained scholarships from Miguel and from private families and we work
together in order to make this dream come true.
And it was pretty amazing because I can't tell you the amount of times that I
said,
Henry,
I'm not sure this is going to happen this year.
I said,
maybe in future years.
But as you know,
a college and the West is very expensive.
And coming from a background where it,
both of his parents were killed during the genocide,
a while his mother was actually breastfeeding him and had his twin brother on,
on the back,
he has a twin.
And a,
what was amazing was,
um,
I was sitting with these two boys on their birthday having dinner and his
brother,
Eric said to me,
do you believe in miracles?
I thought to myself,
I don't really know,
I don't think about miracle set often.
And he said,
well,
can you imagine that a boy from this background in Rwanda growing up with a
grandmother in a pretty poor neighborhood is a heading off to McGill and a few
weeks with his visa,
his scholarship,
uh,
his apartment,
everything sorted out.
And I said,
yeah,
it's pretty incredible.
And he looked at me and said,
no,
this is,
this is a miracle.
It's not just pretty incredible.
And so,
uh,
he really changed my perspective.
But a,
Henry and I are in touch on a weekly basis and,
uh,
I'll be working with him throughout his entire college experience.
And,
uh,
I'm excited for the opportunities that youth have both in Rwanda and out.
The last thing I want to mention about youth as peace education.
And very,
very briefly,
the organization I used to work for a ages trust and the Kigali genocide
memorial started this,
uh,
educational program around peace and critical thinking for youth.
And this is another aspect of post genocide and postconflict recovery is how to
reeducate and help youth really understand the power of their decisions and make
sure that they could both understand their past in order to go forward toward
the future.
So this shows the story of Eduardo who is one of the upstanders during the
genocide and kind of through pictures on this mobile exhibit.
And these are graphic designs,
take students through his story and then afterward they sit with facilitators
and go through some of the main themes about,
as I said,
critical thinking,
the power of individual choice and the power of a kind of living together in the
aftermath of conflict.
So the next thing I want to touch on is a psychological healing and trauma
healing.
And as I said,
I'm not going to tell you completely the standards stories.
Um,
this is a picture I took when I saw at met.
the all female drumming group,
um,
whose name is,
in Goleman's Shah,
which means a new drum.
And so I'm drumming and Rwanda traditionally reserved for men,
uh,
and,
prohibited from women who are usually prohibited from even touching drums or
even approaching the drummer who used to perform for the king.
But this drum group came about after the genocide with Hutu and Tutsi women
coming together of all different ages of different backgrounds of socioeconomic
backgrounds.
Um,
other backgrounds came together to learn this and actually,
um,
to show that they are strong both physically and picking up the drums and
actually drumming and also that are strong mentally and emotionally.
And this is a very interesting example of psychological health because it's not
what we usually think of where people sit and counseling groups or individual
counseling,
uh,
which takes a long time and is very slow and there is also costly and expensive.
There are amazing things about,
uh,
this kind of trauma counseling.
But in Rwanda,
many people don't access it.
And so,
um,
these kinds of groups which bring people together are pretty incredible.
And after I saw this performance,
I spoke to one of the drummers and she basically said,
you know,
the group is like a new family,
a Rwandans,
a lot of them lost family if not entire members of their family during the
genocide.
And these newly constructed social groups and social networks are incredibly
important for psychological health and trauma healing because the women also
talk about what's going on in their lives.
They celebrate together,
weddings,
births,
deaths,
everything that you would expect a family or a broader community to do,
these women do together.
And there are others examples of these kinds of groups around economic
development and other development that,
um,
how have this benefit of psychological healing.
This is a photo that was actually taken by a very close friend of mine who was a
professional photographer and Rwanda.
And if you look closely,
the photo is of a scar on the stomach of a,
someone in Rwanda.
And I interviewed this person about a year and a half ago and he was very shy,
very quiet.
Uh,
the interview didn't last very long,
but one of the things that really struck me was this discussion of scars.
And,
um,
I spoke to him and said,
he told me he was captured by Interahamwe land,
um,
and had some scars.
And I said to him,
can you,
can you tell me a little bit about your scars?
And what he did was he stood up and he lifted up his shirt and showed me the
scar on his stomach.
Um,
after meeting him the first time I went back to interview him again,
but I was shocked at the kind of vulnerability of showing this like a white
woman in Rwanda,
this scar on his stomach.
Um,
but he wanted to make a statement,
which is,
um,
that some of the scars,
you can see both the psychological and the physical scars and some you can't,
some are hidden under your clothes somewhere hidden in your mind.
Some are hidden until something triggers them and comes out.
But the scars are living with these people are living with Rwandans and we don't
know necessarily when they're going to know,
manifest themselves or in what ways.
And so when working in post conflict societies,
we have to be very,
very,
almost vigilant to the point of,
um,
respect that we can understand coming from kind of non survivor perspectives,
how to work with survivors and others including perpetrators who have trauma of
what happened and what they've done.
Now.
I personally believe that all of us have suffered some form of trauma or some
negative thing.
And it's not about comparing hierarchies of suffering.
What happened to me is not necessarily as bad or you know,
it doesn't feel as bad as what happened to you or what happened to a survivor.
But the point is figuring out what is the human level that we can connect on,
just show the most basic level of respect for someone who's been through these
experiences.
And,
um,
I've been very lucky to have had the opportunity to see scars like these,
which definitely make you uncomfortable to have them photographed and use for
educational purposes for teaching.
And also to understand that,
um,
again,
the scars don't always comment at the same time.
And so one thing I wanted to mention about scars as well as during the 1994,
I'm sorry,
during the commemoration period that starts on April 7th,
every year I often get texts on whatsapp or on,
uh,
on text message and say,
you know,
Samantha,
I'm not doing well.
And I got a little concerned and I think to myself,
well,
I'm not a counselor and I've met people in Rwanda and they're telling me that
all of a sudden something happened and they're not doing well.
And so it's very surprising the ways that people in which people will reach out
to their friends and uh,
other people who they've met.
And sometimes you feel,
I don't have a strong connection with that person,
but for some reason they felt they could trust me or maybe I was the only one
online.
Right?
Maybe I was the only one online in that moment and they wanted to speak to
someone.
But you know,
letting them know I'm not a counselor,
but I'm here as a friend.
I can advise you in that capacity.
But it's amazing the amount of text messages and messages I get during this
period.
Um,
and the emotional stress both on the individual and myself,
uh,
just being very completely honest and vulnerable with you.
Um,
but that's the responsibility of working in,
uh,
in this sector
is to accept these relationships as they are and to try your best to do what you
can do.
Um,
and none of us is perfect,
but,
uh,
even just being there for someone is sometimes enough.
I had someone write to me very late at night and in the morning wrote back and
said,
um,
I was thinking of um,
basically drinking over drinking.
Um,
and after I spoke to you,
I went to sleep and I realized that I would wake up tomorrow and feel maybe a
little bit better and all I did was take a minute to communicate with him and I
didn't know about any of these thoughts in his mind,
but it was pretty incredible.
It was just taking that moment to say,
yes,
I'm here.
Tell me what's up.
I'm going to have to go in a couple of minutes to get back to work.
But whatever it is,
uh,
sometimes you don't know the impact of the people who you are interacting with.
So the last point I want to touch on is kind of an uplifting point and it's
definitely appropriate for those of you working at Google and working in this
sector,
um,
is technology and research.
And one of the things that has been happening in Rwanda is the startup company
of safe motos.
So safe photos has helped Rwanda separate good drivers from what they call the
crazy ones.
Um,
motorbikes are,
and,
uh,
a very common way to get around in Rwanda,
especially in the capitol city of Kigali.
And most of the motorbikes are unregistered and most accidents also happen on
motorbikes.
And so safe Motos,
uh,
has an APP that's very similar to Uber that encourages a motorbike taxi riders
to contact safe Motos who's I'm a Modo.
Drivers are trained in safety and there's also a record given on how many
accidents they've had and um,
what kind of driving record they have.
So,
not only are you able to be picked up in a safe place,
but you're also able to know kind of the rating of your driver.
Very,
again,
very similar to Uber,
the two founders,
Peter car,
Yuki,
and they're at Nash.
Peter is actually a close friend of mine,
uh,
and they're doing amazing,
amazing work.
Um,
and they also are interested because I'm belonging to safe.
Motos not only helps the rider but actually helps the driver and Modo drivers
are one of these,
uh,
kind of segments of the population that you don't really know a lot about them.
You don't know if they're a survivor,
you have no idea if they were a former perpetrator.
Oftentimes they don't speak English or French.
Uh,
it's hard for Westerners to communicate with them,
but they are a huge segment of the population.
Many of them are coming from villages or other places to the capital city of
Kigali to drive a motorbike and make money.
And so they're one of the people that we really don't know a lot about.
Groups of people that we really don't know a lot about but are heavily prevalent
in society in Kigali.
And so one of the amazing things is that I'm,
authorities are often ambivalent towards moto drivers,
um,
as they associate them with crime and disorder,
but showing but becoming part of safe motos helps them,
um,
show that they're legitimate people just trying to make an income and really
helps them gain legitimacy in the eyes of authorities and the eyes of the rest
of society.
So it's actually has a dual purpose and helping people ride safely and reduce
accidents,
but also helping in societal recovery,
showing that these Modo drivers are not young men coming to create problems in
the city,
but they're actually just trying to make a living and the best way that they
can.
And you can even see this as a free concert,
uh,
an advertisement that says red with safe motos there.
So they're doing their advertising and saying,
you know,
you want to come to this concert,
great ride with safe motos.
Be Safe on your way.
And,
uh,
it's an amazing initiative.
There's been a lot of press on safe motos and uh,
they'd become a pretty incredible startup.
But I think what's amazing about them is their commitment to developing the
sector of Modo drivers,
um,
within the post complex society to kind of get rid of this concept of,
you know,
the,
the young men trying to cause problems in this city,
which is a theoretical concept in post conflict societies that the young men
come to the cities and they want to cause problems and they don't have homes or
education.
And this is kind of combating that stereotype.
And the last thing I want to mention kind of bringing it back to um,
to memory and technology is I'm the genocide archive for Wanda's new web page.
And so the genocide archive of Rwanda,
um,
is able to bring access and knowledge to individuals around the world.
Um,
they have pre scan and prescreened all of their data that they put online where
people can watch videos,
they can watch propaganda videos of the,
uh,
of the Hutu hardline regimes before 1994.
They could find documents,
they can take a virtual tour of the memorial sites,
which is pretty incredible.
Um,
and these are some of the positive things about this,
this a website.
Um,
and some of the questions also exists,
which is,
um,
how or in what ways can they be meaningful for the local community on the
ground.
They have a huge reach for people who are international.
But what about survivors,
perpetrators,
ordinary citizens who are living on the ground,
who might not have Internet access or who might not be interested in this kind
of education,
um,
who was their primary audience and do these issues reconcile themselves in the
same platform?
The issue of catering to a number of communities and a number of individuals.
Um,
and so that's one of the things that I think about when looking at these online
platforms or these virtual tours of sites is that yes,
a lot of people cannot travel to Rwanda and see these sights firsthand or
understand what happened firsthand.
So they're getting wonderful education through a platform like the genocide
archive of Rwanda.
But at the same time,
we don't want to do that.
At the expense of a understanding and making memorials,
uh,
and other,
other archives meaningful for survivors and former perpetrators.
So I'm going to end there for a minute and I know I've given you a lot of
information,
a lot of stories,
a lot of food for thought.
But what I'm hoping is that this kind of has given you an understanding of
Rwanda as an example for post conflict societies writ large.
And one of my main,
uh,
kind of the core tenants of my research is that,
um,
we have to go deep and we have to go broad,
right?
So we have to go deep to understand that each context is different and that
Rwanda,
what,
what works in Rwanda,
what doesn't work in Rwanda might be different from another place.
But at the same time,
there are themes that cut across post conflict societies and can help us rethink
wherever we are.
And so I want you to think back about what you knew and believed about post
genocide Rwanda or post conflict societies writ large and what you've learned
that might complicate or compliment your initial thoughts.
This was not meant to be a talk that will clarify everything for you.
Rather talk to get you thinking about these issues,
about the range of issues and about how you might be able to fit in.
So I want to close with a quote from,
uh,
one of my idols in the world.
Um,
Desmond Tutu,
which is do your little bit of good where you're at.
It's those little bits of good put together that overwhelm the world.
And so start our responsibility,
the ability to do it all.
But,
um,
I hope that today this kind of compels you to think about where you fit into the
post conflict society.
Even if you are sitting at your office here in Cambridge or even if you travel a
little bit to some places that might be considered postconflict to delve into
their history and look and think about what you can do in that very,
very small way.
Just as I said,
staying up at night for five minutes,
whatsapp conversation kept a friend from,
uh,
over overdrinking and kept him waking up the next morning.
And I'm glad to say he's doing really well.
Uh,
what are those things that you can bring to the table?
Um,
with that,
I want to say thank you.
I want to say thank you to the Google office at Cambridge,
to everyone who came today.
Um,
I'm happy to take questions and comments,
but again,
I really hope this opened your eyes to a subject that I really care about and
that's that I'm passionate about and that I want to share with people who are,
um,
hopefully also interested in these kinds of issues.
So once again,
thank you to all of you to Google and,
uh,
I hope you enjoyed the talk and I'm very happy to entertain questions.
Hi.
Um,
can you talk a little bit more about transitional justice and,
uh,
in the context of the Rwandan genocide,
what maybe just giving us more details of what happened with tribunals and the
historical facts?
Yes,
absolutely.
So,
um,
as I mentioned,
I'm,
I'll give you kind of the transitional justice one o one,
which we do have a Clark,
a seminar on transitional justice at Clark University.
I'm actually going to give it to in like a minute.
Um,
don't tell any professor who teaches that class that I've done this.
No,
I'm just kidding there.
My advisor,
um,
so basically transitional justice,
as I mentioned,
is a type of justice that accompanies states and societies from conflict to
peace.
It's,
I'm employed in the case of extraordinary crimes and extraordinary grievances.
Mass violence,
mass atrocity is,
that doesn't only mean a number,
but it also means in scale of participation and of targeting.
So it's not.
Um,
so basically the concept is that ordinary justice or ordinary legal courts
cannot really,
uh,
provide justice for these extraordinary crimes like genocide,
crimes against humanity,
war crimes,
et cetera.
Um,
so transitional justice has been this array of mechanisms,
um,
kind of found it and used by the international community since the 1970s or
eighties to address some of these issues that ordinary legal justice cannot
address.
So in Rwanda,
um,
we see kind of the two,
two forms we see legal justice,
which I said again,
focuses mostly on perpetrators,
on punishment and what we call symbolic justice,
which focuses more on victims and survivors.
And this more future looking,
both are important and both kind of must be there in a post conflict society for
transitional justice to do with job in Rwanda.
We have,
um,
three main cases that I'll mention.
One is the establishment of the International Criminal Tribunal for Rwanda,
the ICTR,
which was established by the United Nations Security Council in 1940 in 1995.
And this basically was a implemented kind of like the International Criminal
Tribunal for the former Yugoslavia and in the legacy and tradition of Nuremberg
tribunals,
ah,
after World War II to try the perpetrators,
but not only the perpetrators,
but the big fish,
the ones who were the organizers,
the masterminds who were instrumental and planning and carrying out the,
uh,
1994 genocide in Rwanda.
And so the ICTR,
I was an operation for 20 years.
It closed in 2015.
Um,
I do have statistics on how many people they tried,
but it wasn't too,
too many.
Um,
and it was also very difficult because it operates with the bureaucracy of a
tribunal,
right?
So you have trials,
you have appeals,
you have a whole mechanism dedicated.
Uh,
the court was also in Urrutia,
Tanzania.
It was not in Rwanda,
so there was outreach,
uh,
about the happenings of the court in Urrutia.
There was outreach into Rwanda.
Um,
but you know,
reviews are pretty mixed,
so it goes for the big fish and a closed in 2015.
Um,
and there were some very well known trials that came out of there including the
[inaudible] case,
which,
uh,
proved that genocide is a form,
I'm sorry,
that rape is a form of genocide.
Rape is a systematic form of genocide and uh,
it was the first person convicted of rape during genocide.
Uh,
it's Okayso.
Um,
so in addition to the ICTR,
we have a form of local justice called the good chacha tribunals now.
Gotcha.
Um,
we're typically,
um,
tribunals employed in Rwanda for land disputes where people would come together
and kind of elders are trusted members of society would decide what would happen
in a dispute.
And in 2002,
I think,
or 2005,
this was readopted in Rwanda where there was a local selection of judges and
local individuals would come together kind of in their communities,
literally on the grass.
Um,
perpetrators would confess what they had done and survivors would kind of
forgive them or would then have more knowledge.
Maybe a lot of one thing came out of Gattaca was where the people were buried,
which was a huge deal.
And so these cutoffs of courts were kind of localized forms of justice.
Um,
they also have their critiques in which,
uh,
the judges were not trained judges,
there were no lawyers or representation,
so the questions of due process,
but basically the purpose was,
um,
that the ICTR and the national courts couldn't try the large number of
perpetrators.
The prisons were overflowing and there had to be some practical form of
transitional justice.
And so the cutoff courts were formed in order to kind of try the lower level
perpetrators.
People involved in a property theft,
people involved in assisted,
uh,
Kelly,
good murder,
things like that.
So those were the good chacha courts,
which clothes and stuff.
And 12.
And then we have this third section,
which is the symbolic justice,
which are kind of more what I discuss and absolutely more what I study,
which are,
um,
memorialization ans commemorations,
creation of memorial sites,
burial,
um,
creation of families,
artificial families in the aftermath of the genocide.
Um,
official apologies,
security.
These are all the things I would put under symbolic justice.
So that's kind of the range that transitional justice take specifically in
Rwanda.
Hey,
uh,
how do you think our understanding of post conflict societies and recovery
affects how we look at ongoing conflict?
It's a great question.
Thank you so much.
So I think it's interesting because I was actually speaking with my father
yesterday who's here and,
um,
he said,
haven't we learned anything?
Right.
Um,
and I think a lot of people ask that,
right?
Haven't we learned anything?
The 20th century is a known as the age of genocide,
of the age of conflict.
You know,
uh,
how about we learned anything in how we have seen and viewed post conflict
societies and the challenges they have.
Don't we want to prevent that?
And of course we do.
I think the difficulty though is that there are so many factors at play that
when a new conflict arises,
what worked or didn't work,
for example,
in Rwanda in 1994 in terms of intervention may or may not work in Syria today.
It may or may not backfire.
And that's why those local a specialized analysts are just as important as the
ones working at the broad level.
I think the what,
um,
what's particularly important is fact finding and postconflict is when we're
able to win,
the conflict kind of subsided.
Now of course,
conflict doesn't end when the fighting ends,
right?
There's elements of protracted conflict that continue long,
long after a ceasefire agreement is,
is a signed or,
or,
or fighting physically ends.
And so I think looking at the complexities and also the fact finding,
understanding what really happened,
what were the patterns of violence,
what were some of the triggers and analyzing these things,
analyzing propaganda,
dehumanization,
tactics,
um,
group think and group mentality,
masculinities and,
and a initiation into masculine masculinizing groups,
economic problems,
all of these factors at play help us get a really good understanding in
hindsight of what happened.
Postconflict how do we now apply them to what's going on
in,
you know,
active conflict.
And I think that's $1 million question.
So I don't have a great answer for you,
but I do think that understanding the patterns and accurately understanding
what's happening in current conflicts is really important and doing more
documentation as the conflicts going on.
One very quick example is Burundi.
So we have an ongoing conflict in Burundi,
the country next to Rwanda and um,
some analysts,
analysts from State Department and elsewhere.
Basically trying to figure out what's happening on the ground now and to
correctly identify what kind of violences is and what factors are happening so
that when they are deciding how to intervene,
which has been taking a long time,
but I'm hoping will happen soon when UN and other western states at other
African states and Aau are deciding what to do,
if they correctly more or less identify the elements of the problem,
they can create better solutions.
And so that's where I'm hoping we're going,
which is being able to kind of disaggregate and then bring it,
build it back,
you know,
does aggregate into themes and build it back up to prevent.
But unfortunately what works in one place might not work in another place.
And we've seen that a lot.
So I'm not trying to be pessimistic,
I'm just trying to say that,
okay,
it's a lot of work and we have to do it well.
Oh,
why did I create a presentation as a in north London who went deep in the
subject?
Not only you read the books,
like any other person could read the book,
but,
uh,
you made an impact.
And do we make an impact because you have met those,
like Shawna's,
um,
who is victimized during the genocide.
MMM.
In your experience,
it's really sad to get to the point of justice.
As you,
you have explained transitional,
you know,
any orders,
phases,
three phases of it or what do you think of bringing justice?
When we hear the whole wall,
he had people who denied the existence of this genocide the most,
let's say the [inaudible] the United States and there's a way in Europe,
um,
some of the perpetrators have fled the country and that all over the world.
And uh,
they have come about this denial that the genocide has not taken the place.
Others as we come to say,
uh,
well we accepted that,
that the genocide had taken place,
but there was a double genocide.
Um,
another group will come and say,
well,
this is the group of the denials of genocide,
yet they're not,
is one dance in that two group of Rwandan perpetrators and the have not been
even the country.
They go ahead and if I could use the word preach here and there about that kind
of denial,
uh,
how,
oh,
what do you bring that into being or bringing a sort of justice to these kind of
stories around the denial of justice.
Thank you.
Thank you professor buying Ghana.
A professor buying Anna brings up a really great point,
which is,
um,
what forms is denial take and what do we do about it?
Um,
denial is a problem and it's not a new one.
We've seen it with Armenia.
We've seen it after the Holocaust.
After almost every major conflict,
we have people who,
uh,
for some reason,
whether it's political or personal cannot handle the truth of what happened.
Um,
and try to kind of give another,
another example.
So one way this happens is by completely denying one way is by manipulating the
facts and saying it was not a genocide.
It was a civil war or um,
yes,
Tutsi were killed in 1994,
but also there were crimes against who to in 1995,
96,
97.
Um,
and that,
um,
is that,
that concept of double genocide,
that it was not only Tutsi who were killed,
but after that who too were killed as they were exiting the country and were
targeted.
Um,
that's the theory of double genocide.
And to that,
I would say two things about,
about dealing with deniers.
One way we can deal with deniers is to ignore them,
is not to give them a platform to speak,
um,
because when deniers are interviewed on television or they have a chance to,
uh,
right.
You know,
in media and of course there's free speech and in these countries you mentioned
people can publish anywhere they want,
but if they're known denialist,
if they're causing harm to people,
um,
there are ways to choose someone else.
Someone who maybe has a more balanced perspective.
And it's not considered a now outright denialist.
When,
uh,
when,
when any news outlet interviews people,
um,
one survivor told me that denial feels like the genocide is happening over again
because basically you're,
their family was killed during the genocide.
And then when someone denies it,
they deny your right of acknowledgement.
They deny your right to grieve,
they deny your right to feel how you want to feel.
They deny what happened to you and they're harming your ability to move forward
because you cannot be recognized.
And we see this kind of in limbo situation in Armenia where people are very hurt
because I'm their situation and their reality is not being recognized.
And so I think,
um,
but besides kind of this,
this ignoring and not engaging because denialists will keep,
as you said,
preaching regardless of what factual evidence comes.
I think the second point is,
um,
is this categorization that's really helpful.
I think the legal crime category is genocide,
war crimes,
crimes against humanity and all that has been put into developing these very,
um,
thorough categories is helpful.
So when the UN deemed that Rwanda was a genocide,
um,
there are facts and evidence in terms of fact finding missions in terms of
intent,
intent to destroy a group in whole or in part intent to destroy the two t
people.
Um,
these were present and proven in the case of Rwanda.
And so it is a genocide according to international legal order,
if that's what you respect.
And most people,
I think most countries do.
And so sticking to those definitions and the facts is where you can't go wrong.
You know,
at a certain point if you start getting into the emotion and trying to convince
people that can get very messy,
but the facts of the matter are the ones that stick there and the ones that are
grounded in international law,
international theory,
that's where I think we can really keep continuing with,
uh,
helping to fight denial.
But denial is very harmful for,
for everyone.
And it's a big,
big issue in Rwanda right now.
So thank you so much.
Well,
thank you everyone.